hey 42 here if you're traveling deep in
the American Midwest through the barren
plains of Nebraska you'll pass a tiny
collection of buildings all but one of
them are abandoned and decaying you'll
probably pass by anything nothing more
about it
but this is the smallest town in all of
America with a grand population of just
one Elsie Island mano y is the only
officially incorporated municipality in
the United States with a population of
just one sure you may know a weird
friend who moved out of his mother's
basement into a mobile home in the
forest because he thinks the government
have tapped his phone and put a camera
in his box of Cheerios for that doesn't
count
unlike mano y your crazy friends trailer
is not officially a town but mana white
wasn't always so tiny it was once a
thriving town a small town but a town
nonetheless mano y was founded in 1902
by European settlers in the Czech
Republic it reached its peak in the
1930s when it boasted a handsome
population of 150 there was even a high
school in modern wine but a draw of the
big city in the job site office was too
great and one by one the city's younger
residents moved away from mana why
including gal C's own children by the
late 1900s all that was left was Elsie
and her husband Rudy despite their only
being a two of them they had a nice
little place to call home
Rudy ran the local library and Elsie ran
the tavern now he might be wondering why
a town with a grand population of two
needs a library in a tavern but the two
establishments get quite a lot of custom
from passing travelers and visiting
farmers from nearby towns who were
probably quite thankful to stumble
across Elsie's one-woman beer Shack
because this is the middle of absolutely
nowhere after all unfortunately in 2004
half of the town of mono why tragically
died Rudy sadly passed away and so the
town sign had to be changed from a
population of two to just one but good
old Elsie as devastated as she was
continued running the tavern and library
all by herself and still does to this
day she spends most of her days
socialising with the vast assortment of
visit
that passed through the town stop for
one of her famous homemade burgers but
it doesn't stop there
since Elsie is mana wise only resident
she is also the self elected Talmer as
well as bartender and librarian running
a town is no small feat certain legal
obligations have to be met even if it is
only just for one person Elsie has to
pay herself taxes and she has to grant
herself her own yearly liquor license to
run the tavern she also has to produce a
municipal road plan every year to secure
state funding to keep it for street
lights running mono I must be the only
town in America
where you can get served a burger and a
beer by the town mayor oh maybe not
because 30 minutes down the road for
mono why is a little town called gross
yes seriously someone named a town gross
gross is twice the size of mono why with
a grande population of two man and wife
Marian mike finnegan are the town's only
residents and just like elsie of mana
why they run a tavern and mike is also
self elected town man gross and money
why are representative of a larger
problem going on all across the Great
Plains of America people are rapidly
abandoning small towns in search of
better jobs and opportunities in large
cities large chain stores are also
eradicating the need for farms but LC is
staying strong and stubbornly refuses to
move despite the fact that she actually
lives in a ghost town a few years ago
this is one of the town's main streets
now overgrown with vegetation the local
church is boarded up and all the houses
except Elsie's are decaying into the
ground she likes to have a laugh of
herself though the mana YN advertises
the coldest beer in town yeah it's also
the only beer in town thanks for
watching welcome to the weirdest city in
Alaska Whittier but Whittier is the city
that forgot how to city because it is
home to just 220 people there are hidden
oil wells all over Los Angeles these
secret oil wells are hidden right in
plain sight some are next to schools and
shopping malls